revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 Rosa Pérez mateu con nosotros
en el estudio Rosa Qué bueno tenerla de
vuelta vamos a abrir Entonces esta
revista de prensa con la editorial del
periódico chino el global Times que hace
referencia al encuentro ayer entre el
presidente chinompín y su homólogo ruso
Vladimir Putin como lo analiza
recordemos que el global Times por
supuesto es un periódico no ha llegado
digamos alineado al gobierno chino
efectivamente Buenos días Raúl y el
titular ya lo dice un poco todo dice el
encuentro de los líderes chino y rusos
Pink y Vladimir Putin inyecta
estabilidad en un mundo cambiante y en
desorden dice que en el encuentro el
ambiente fue tan positivo y amistoso
como siempre como es costumbre y que
dice en un mundo cambiante la única
certeza es el apoyo mutuo entre
Moscú y Beijing a pesar señala de que
Estados Unidos intenté interferir entre
las relaciones de ambos países sobre
todo señala global Times desde que
empezó cito literalmente el conflicto
entre Rusia y Ucrania además asegura que
la alianza entre Rusia y China no es
contra Estados Unidos como Washington
intenta hacer creer sino contra la
hegemonía que Estados Unidos intenta
imponer cambiamos ahora información a
Rosa hablamos de la Reina Isabel II la
bbc responde la pregunta se puede
protestar en los eventos reales bien
este aspecto ha generado bastante
polémica no y es que en el contexto de
las ceremonias oficiales no por el luto
de Isabel II distintas personas han sido
detenidas durante algunas horas
precisamente por protestar contra la
monarquía lo que ha abierto el debate
precisamente sobre si se está impidiendo
limitando el ejercicio de la libertad de
expresión efectivamente no Y en este
caso pues ha habido algunos ejemplos más
mediatizados que otros sobre todo en
Escocia en edimburgo por razones pues
evidentes no de relación entre Escocia y
la corona británica por ejemplo algunos
casos que destaca la bbc es cuando una
mujer Pues protestó con un cartel que
pedía abolir la monarquía un hombre
gritó a Carlos III quien a lo eligió
otro hombre llamó pervertido al príncipe
Andrew recordemos por su supuesta
implicación en el caso efectivamente de
Jeffrey epstein y dice la división si
bien en Reino Unido está permitida la
protesta pacífica es un derecho
garantizado hay límites no a este
derecho que puede imponer la policía en
distintos casos por ejemplo para
proteger la seguridad nacional para
prevenir el desorden la criminalidad o
la alteración de la paz disposiciones
que evidentemente son muy ambiguas e
interpretables no Y además hay una ley
de 2000 a 22 una nueva ley de seguridad
que fue muy polémica este año en Reino
Unido queda además un margen de maniobra
a la interpretación de la policía claro
y precisamente el butters institute se
hizo eco un análisis sobre la falta
diversidad digamos en la prensa
británica en la prensa de Reino Unido
evidenciada a raíz de la muerte de la
reina Isabel segunda Rosa Qué dice este
informe bien Es que parte de una
anécdota de un hecho pues muy destacable
Y es que el autor Marcus Rider
especialista en diversidad en los medios
de comunicación tenía el mismo 8 de
septiembre el día que murió la Reina
Isabel II una reunión con el director
general de la bbc David para abordar no
la situación de diversidad de falta de
diversidad y de inclusión en la
corporación pública de medios británica
no y dice la reunión se desarrolló sin
interrupción a pesar de que el director
general de la bbc ya estaba alerta
Porque en cualquier momento sabía que le
podían notificar el fallecimiento de
Isabel II y abordaron un poco la falta
la carencia de diversidad en general
estructural dentro de la bbc pero dice
antes de despedirse Marcos Rider alertó
no al directora general de la
universidad diciéndole que la
corporación claramente no estaba
preparada en términos de diversidad y de
inclusión por la noticia que estaba a
punto de caer y era la muerte Pues de
Isabel II y dice los días Solo me han
dado la razón no solo en la bbc sino en
los medios de comunicación británicos en
general no dice que el impacto la
uniformidad con la que se ha cubierto
este fallecimiento y dice que en estos
momentos es muy importante destacar no
la diversidad de opiniones en Pues un
país porque si no se está excluyendo a
ciertos sectores de la sociedad
diciéndoles que su opinión pues no es
representativa de la nación digamos y
que no pertenecen a ese país dice uno
solo tiene que mirar Black Twitter o ir
en Twitter para darse cuenta que hay
opiniones muy distintas a las que han
predominado los editoriales de los
medios de comunicación británico dicen
si bien algunos medios incluyendo
opiniones de personas que claramente no
están nada de luto por la muerte de
Isabel II relegar estos discursos a los
espacios de opinión todavía acentúa más
esta diferencia entre él nosotros
representado por los editoriales no la
opinión británica frente al ellos ellos
no los que digamos no digamos están como
decíamos de luto por la muerte de Isabel
II dice además la falta de diversidad
también implica una cierta ceguera a la
hora de cubrir ciertas noticias porque
como decíamos las protestas se han
enmarcado en un debate sobre la libertad
de expresión cuando dice es una cuestión
también de representatividad por ejemplo
en Escocia un tercio de la población
quiere que se acabe ya la monarquía y la
herencia de la Reina Isabel segunda bien
ha sido también polémica porque es una
de las personas más ricas del mundo y
entre los 420 millones de dólares que
pasarán libres de impuestos a su hijo
Carlos III también ha habido otros
hechos destacables y es que entre los
bienes que heredará su hijo se
encuentran 32 cisnes un número
indeterminado de delfines ballenas y
esturiones que viven en aguas británicas
explicación de este hecho dice el país
esta medida se tomó en el siglo 12
cuando los cisnes eran un manjar y su
caza furtiva amenazaba la especie se
optó Entonces por adjudicar al rey la
propiedad de Estos y otros animales para
preservar su población una tradición que
se instauró hace 800 años y que sigue
vigente a día de hoy por otro lado la
fortuna Privada de la Reina Isabel II se
distribuirá en secreto probablemente con
un testamento sellado y eso es algo que
también una tradición que se estableció
en 1900 cuando el príncipe Felipe detec
dio sus joyas más valiosas a su amante
en lugar digamos de a su esposa dice el
país No parece que hay amantes en la
herencia de Isabel II pero digamos El
testamento privado evitará que se sepan
los posibles beneficiados o perjudicados
dentro de una saga con abundantes
enfrentamientos y escándalos
Muchas gracias por toda la información
de revista de prensa ya nos vemos y
vamos ahora a saludar a nuestro invitado
al día como siempre empecé a tenerla